it's the only way out of european and
this would test even the fit and healthy
but those still fleeing are the most
vulnerable the elderly the frail and the
very young
those who've left this dangerous journey
to the last and they're having to pick
their way across those unable to get
over themselves have to be carried
painfully slowly so they don't slip
despite the desperation to get to the
other side
the man in red is offering some comfort
to the old man as he puts all his trust
in strangers taking enormous risks
themselves
this is an absolutely incredible scene
there are dozens of people like this man
who are having to be held and taken over
a really precarious rickety bridge and
do it slowly because you can't have too
many people on that bridge at one time
or else it will just snap and they try
to do this quickly before the firing
starts again
some of these people have already walked
several kilometers to get to this point
carrying on their backs the loved ones
they could not leave behind
and this is no agreed safe corridor
these people know this route has been
attacked multiple times already
so they raced out as quickly as they
could crying babies helped by volunteers
come on mom he's calling
many of them have been shot at or
survived shelling
smile her partner says he wants her to
be brave in front of our cameras
the courage of these people in these the
most difficult and risky of
circumstances is quite astonishing the
pulling together of them all an absolute
inspiration to witness
uh here we have shoots all everywhere we
don't see anything but we uh listen
yes yes and we know uh some uh some
streets uh kills people uh near my house
uh kills women
yesterday
[Music]
the russian soldiers are very close
we're told only a hundred meters down
the end of this road the urgency to get
people out is stepping up a beat
20
[Music]
two civilians one woman one with
children and one
from um
we're all buried yes yes in the park and
square where uh
two weeks ago
children with
playing
ukrainian soldiers are pushing into
urban trying to hold back the russian
troops
they have to about a third of the town
is now under control of the russians
putting them right on the western
doorstep of the capital
the ukrainians say they bombed the
bridge which used to be the main route
into kiev and the russians only have to
cross this to easily get within striking
distance of the capital
those running away from this slow but
relentless military advance told us of
being under siege for days surrounded by
explosions until they could last no
longer no light no water no everything
and
we can't live in our houses right now
and then a remarkable act of kindness
from those who've just escaped with
their lives
it's for international women's day she
says
in the face of such fear and danger
having lost everything some coming out
were more worried about us
everything's okay everything will be
good she tells us trust me we will
survive we will escape everything will
be good
don't be sad or negative she tells me
hold on protect yourself and take care
of yourself
the road out is littered with
possessions they once thought essential
now just surviving is the priority
sometimes we
uh we thought
this is the last
second of our life
it was very scared
yeah but it was yeah they made sure
yodel the cat made it too but also
insisted the world needs to help them
now what should they do about about this
should do
close
uh
they should close
they're fighting the battle of their
lives but there's a sense they're only
delaying the inevitable
they're preparing to lay mines to
protect the capitol road
and all the men escaping urban in the
west have their documents checked
and they're tested on their ukrainian
they're acutely aware here that russian
saboteurs might try to sneak into the
capital hiding amongst the terrified
civilians
so while the russians are still
advancing they take any window to get
people out any way they can
they've somehow survived the most
atrocious conditions in a town under
attack and under siege
but it's by no means over and from
somewhere they find the reserves to push
through this terror
because everyone here is horrified at
the thought of suffering the same fate
as other areas pulverized by the foreign
troops moving in
alex crawford sky news earpin